.
>> ALL RIGHT.
NICK, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
AND "OUTFRONT" NOW, PENTAGON
PRESS SECRETARY JOHN KIRBY.
ADMIRAL, IT SEEMS LIKE THERE'S
INCREASING CONCERN FOR U.S.
OFFICIALS ABOUT PUTIN'S NEXT
STEPS SO TODAY WE HEAR FROM THE
DNI, CHIEF THERE SAYS PUTIN IS
POSSIBLY GOING TO ESCALATE, SAID
PUTIN COULD TURN TO MORE DRASTIC
MEANS, WE HEARD THE CIA DIRECTOR
BILL BURNS SAY PUTIN IS IN A
FRAME OF MIND WHERE HE DOESN'T
BELIEVE HE CAN AFFORD TO LOSE.
ADMIRAL, IS SOMETHING SPECIFIC
GUIDING THESE COMMENTS?
>> WHAT'S HELPING US GUIDE THE
COMMENTS IS WE DON'T EXACTLY
KNOW WHAT PUTIN WILL DO, WE KNOW
THEY'RE FOCUSING FIRE POWER IN
SPECIFICALLY THE EASTERN PART OF
THE COUNTRY BUT WHAT'S NOT
CLEAR, SHOULD HE GAIN THAT
TERRITORY, WHERE DOES HE GO FROM
THERE?
DOES HE SAY THAT'S THE END, OR
TRY TO ADVANCE FORCES FURTHER
WEST AND EVEN TRY TO THREATEN
KYIV AGAIN?
THAT'S WHAT'S CONCERNING
INTELLIGENCE ANALYSTS AS WELL AS
FOLKS AT THE PENTAGON IS WE
DON'T HAVE A CLEAR PICTURE BUT
HE HASN'T LEFT HIMSELF A WHOLE
LOT OF OPTIONS JUST FROM HIS OWN
RHETORIC.
TALKED YESTERDAY AT THE VICTORY
DAY PARADE OF RIDDING UKRAINE OF
NAZIS.
WE KNOW THAT'S A RIDICULOUS
CLAIM IN TERMS OF WHO THE
UKRAINIANS ARE BUT IF THAT'S
YOUR GOAL, YOUR AIM, THAT'S A
PRETTY MAXIMALIST GOAL, NOT
REALLY CLEAR WHAT HE HAS IN MIND
BUT I THINK THAT'S WHAT'S
GETTING US THE CONCERN.
>> SO TODAY, RUSSIA FIRED
THROUGH HYPERSONIC MISSILES AT
ODESA.
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS CALLED THIS
A CONSEQUENTIAL WEAPON AND SAID
IT'S ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE TO STOP
IT BECAUSE OF ITS SPEED, CAN
OBVIOUSLY EVADE A LOT OF
DETECTION METHODS.
HE SAYS THERE'S A REASON THEY'RE
USING IT.
WHAT IS THAT REASON?
DO YOU SEE SOMETHING BEHIND THIS
INCREASE THAT WE'VE SEEN, TO BE
WITNESSING, IN THE USE OF THESE
HYPER SONIC MISSILES.
>> WE CAN'T ACTUALLY CONFIRM
THAT HYPER SONICS WERE USED
AGAINST ODESA, THAT SAID, WE
KNOW THE RUSSIANS HAVE USED
HYPERSONICS IN UKRAINE BEFORE
AND IT'S A COMBINATION OF
THINGS.
COULD BE THAT HE'S CONCERNED
ABOUT THE NIMBLE AND EFFECTIVE
UKRAINIAN AIR DEFENSES AND
AVOIDING THOSE AIR DEFENSES BUT
ALSO COULD BE LIKELY TWO OTHER
THINGS, ONE, TO TEST THESE
SYSTEMS OPERATIONALLY.
THEY'VE TESTED THEM OUTSIDE OF
COMBAT BUT NOW THEY'RE TESTING
THEM IN A WARZONE TO SEE HOW
EFFECTIVE THEY ACTUALLY ARE AND
NUMBER TWO, TO SEND A STRONG
MESSAGE POTENTIALLY TO THE WEST,
TO THE UNITED STATES, THAT I
HAVE THIS CAPABILITY, THAT THIS
IS A DIFFICULT TO DEFEAT
CAPABILITY SO MAKING IT CLEAR HE
DOESN'T WANT THE WEST MORE
INVOLVED WITH UKRAINE THAN IT
ALREADY IS.
>> BUT AS HE'S TESTING SOMETHING
LIKE THIS, TO SEE HOW IT WORKS
ON THE BATTLE FIELD, JUST MAKES
ME WONDER, ADMIRAL, HOW TO PUT
IN THE CONTEXT WHAT THE DIRECTOR
OF NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE SAID
TODAY WHICH HE SAID PUTIN COULD
TURN TO MORE DRASTIC MEANS.
TALKING ABOUT HYPER SONIC
MISSILES HERE BEING USED,
OFFICIALS WE'RE STILL HEARING
SAY NO EMINENT THREAT OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS BUT WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
MORE DRASTIC MEANS OR BILL BURNS
SAYS HE CAN'T AFFORD TO LOSE,
HOW CONFIDENT CAN YOU BE THAT
SOME SORT OF NUCLEAR WEAPON IS
TRULY OFF THE TABLE?
>> WELL LOOK, I THINK WE'RE
WATCHING THIS VERY CLOSELY,
EVERYDAY, ERIN, AND WE'RE
MONITORING AS BEST WE CAN THE
NUCLEAR POSTURE OF RUSSIA.
NOW WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING,
INCLUDING TODAY, THAT WOULD LEAD
US TO BELIEVE THAT WE NEED TO
CHANGE OUR STRATEGIC DID
YOUETERENT POSTURE BUT THE
ESCALATORY RHETORIC COMING OUT
OF PUTIN AND LAVROV, OTHER
RUSSIAN OFFICIALS DOESN'T GIVE
US CAUSE FOR COMFORT.
HE DOES HAVE NUCLEAR WEAPONS AT
HIS DISPOSAL, TACTICAL WEAPONS
FOR SURE, AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
WATCHING THIS AS CLOSE AS WE
CAN.
ALSO, I THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE
THAT ESCALATING THIS BEYOND THE
DEGREE TO WHICH IT'S ALREADY
BEEN ESCALATED AND YOU'VE SEEN
WHAT'S GOING ON OVER THERE IN
KYIV IS NOT GOOD NOT ONLY FOR
THE PEOPLE OF UKRAINE, IT'S NOT
GOOD FOR RUSSIA, NOT GOOD FOR
UNITED STATES, NOT GOOD FOR
EUROPE.
>> ONE FINAL QUESTION FOR YOU
ADMIRAL, IF I MAY, SECRETARY OF
THE ARMY SAID TODAY SHE'S UNSURE
WHETHER THE AMERICAN STOCK OF
JAVELIN MISSILES IS, COULD BE
REPLACED QUICKLY.
IN A ONE YEAR PERIOD, SO MANY
HAVE BEEN GIVEN TO UKRAINE, IT'S
UNCLEAR WHETHER THEY COULD
REPLACE THEM EVEN WITHIN A FULL
YEAR AND THAT REPLACING STOCK OF
STINGERS THAT HAVE BEEN GIVEN
HERE TO THE UKRAINIANS WOULD
TAKE EVEN MORE TIME BECAUSE
THERE ISN'T EVEN A PRODUCTION
LINE FOR STINGER MISSILES NOW.
SENATOR BLUMENTHAL ON THE ARMED
SERVICES COMMITTEE SAID
RECENTLY, PUT IT VERY BLUNTLY,
THE CLOSET IS BARE.
DO YOU HAVE ANY WORRY ABOUT
EXHAUSTING THE U.S. STOCKPILE IN
CASE THE U.S. SHOULD NEED THE
WEAPONS FOR ITSELF?
>> OBVIOUSLY WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT MAKING SURE WE'RE READY TO
DEFEND THE NATION ACROSS A RANGE
OF CAPABILITY AND SYSTEMS.
I WON'T GET INTO WHAT THE
INVENTORIES ACTUALLY ARE BUT
WITH EVERY SINGLE DRAW-DOWN
PACKAGE THE PRESIDENT APPROVES
AND WE SOURCE, EVERY SINGLE ONE
HAS TO BE ACCOMPANIED BY
ASSESSMENT OF THE PENTAGON,
CHAIRMAN JOINT CHIEFS AND
CERTAINLY SECRETARY AUSTIN TO
MAKE SURE IT'S NOT GOING TO
IMPACT OUR COMBAT READINESS AND
ABILITY TO DEFEND THE NATION AND
THE STINGER LINE, YOU'RE RIGHT
WAS CLOSED BECAUSE WE WEREN'T
BUYING ANYMORE AND IT'S NOT
EXACTLY CLEAR HOW MUCH MORE WE
WOULD NEED IN FUTURE FIGHTS.
WE NOW ARE USING DIFFERENT KINDS
OF SYSTEMS AND MORE ADVANCED
CAPABILITIES SO DOESN'T MEAN WE
HAVE TO REPLACE EVERY JAVELIN OR
STINGER ONE FOR ONE WITH WHAT
WE'VE GIVEN UKRAINE, WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE IT'S ABOUT THE
CAPABILITIES AND WE HAVE VERY
ADVANCED CAPABILITIES AS IT IS
SO WE'RE WATCHING THIS CLOSELY,
WE'RE NOT GOING TO DO ANYTHING
THATS GOING TO IMPIN